ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES WELL FOR
JUST AB FURRED CABALLERO CHIANG
DALLY DODD THE RAZA GALGIANI
LASER GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG
HILL HUESO TANTO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
WARLOCK AROUND. NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN NUMBER BY CASKEY WIENER
WILK. I DON'T WANT. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY BUYER
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO HE
FLAG. BY SENATOR BOARD JUST.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. EVERY DAY WE
WAKE UP WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BEGIN AGAIN. I INVITE YOU TO
REFLECT AGAIN AND BRENDAN
CANNELLA LEAST POLAND. BEGIN
AGAIN TO THE SUMMONING BIRDS TO
THE SIDE OF THE LIGHTS AT THE
WINDOW. BEGIN TO THE STORE AND
ROAR OF MORNING TRAFFIC ALL
ALONG L. STREETS. EVERY
BEGINNING IS A PROMISE BORN IN
LIGHTS AND DYING IN DARK.
DETERMINATION AND EXALTATION OF
SPRINGTIME FLOWERING THE WAY TO
WORK. BEGIN TO THE LONELINESS
BUT CANNOT INS SINCE IT PERHAPS
IS WHAT MAKES US BEGIN. BEGIN
TO WONDER AS UNKNOWN FACES AT
CRYING BIRDS AND THE SUDDEN
RAIN. THOUGH WE LIVE IN A WORLD
THE DREAMS OF AND TING BUT
ALWAYS SEEMS ABOUT TO GIVE IN.
SOMETHING GOES WRONG US
ACKNOWLEDGE CONCLUSION. INSISTS
THOSE REFER EVER AGAIN. A
GRACIOUS GOD THANK YOU FOR THE
BLESSING OF ANOTHER NEW DAY.
MAY ALL BE DO TODAY BEFORE THE
ENCOURAGEMENT OF THOSE WHO
STRUGGLE WITH A LACK OF HOPE.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
CALLS IF YOU COULD PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG THE
STATE. YEAH THE. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR DOLLY.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YEAH.
DOLLARS YEAH. SENATOR DOLLY
FROM THE PRO TEM'S BEST. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I.
I'M HONORED TODAY TO RESIDENT
TO GO TO GRAD CONGRATULATE
RAINY ROBBINS THE WINNER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE'S PHOTO OF THE
YEAR FOR TWENTY TWENTY THE
PHOTO WAS TAKEN IN MY DISTRICT
IN IS HANG OUT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I ACTUALLY
THINK WE HAVE IT RIGHT HERE SO
YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK AT IT. THAT
RANDY IS A NATIVE OF SUSANVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND GREW UP IN
PLUMAS AND LASSEN COUNTIES
THROUGH HIS LOVE OF THE
OUTDOORS AND USING HIS
SECONDHAND CAMERA FROM HIS
GRANDMOTHER RAINY EXPLORED HIS
PASSION FOR PHOTOGRAPHY CAPTION
INCREDIBLE LANDSCAPE AND
WILDLIFE IN CALIFORNIA. RANDY
IS JOIN TODAY IN THE CHAMBER-
WITH HIS WIFE JILL AND THEIR
FOUR CHILDREN CONGRATULATIONS
RAINY ON SHARING YOUR BEAUTIFUL
THIS BEAUTIFUL- PHOTO AND
PASSIONS OF. IT'S ACTUALLY OF A
BALD EAGLE CATCHING. A TRIAL
OFF OF THE LAKE AND SO TAKE A
LOOK AT ITS AWESOME. COULDN'T
CONGRADULATIONS TO RANDY ROBIN.
MA'AM. OKAY. SENATOR DODD. THE
FLOOR MADMAN DOUBTS VETS YES
NUMBERS. I DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER
TO DO THIS UNDER A GERMAN IN
MEMORIES OR ANNOUNCEMENTS ON
THE ROOT PRIVILEGES THE FLOOR
AS FOR THE PURPOSE OF. THE
GRADUATE IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
FORTY NINERS. IN THEIR VICTORY
THIRTY SEVEN TO TWENTY OVER THE
GREEN BAY PACKERS. I THOUGHT TO
BE VERY DISRESPECTFUL TO DO IT
A JOURNEY MEMORY OF THE GREEN
BAY PACKERS SO I DECIDED TO DO
IT HERE. THIS IS A BIG DAY FOR
THE SAME SINCE GOD IT WAS A
GREAT DAY FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
FORTY NINERS WE'RE GOING TO THE
SUPER BALL R. SEVEN SUPERBOWL-
WOULD. ADD UP WITH A FIVE IN
THE RECORD AND THE TEAM THAT WE
HAVE- FEEL VERY COFFIN WE'RE
GOING TO GET A GREAT KIDS CITY
CHIEFS TEAM. BUT GO NINERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR DIED. MOVING
ON THE PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR JACKSON JACKSON FOR AN
INTRODUCTION. AT FROM THE
IMPORTANT TO THE MUNDANE. BUT
NOT AT ALL. IT IS MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE. TO INTRODUCE THE
HONORABLE OR LIKE KEEN THE
NEWLY APPOINTED CONSUL GENERAL
OF IRELAND IN LOS ANGELES. NOW
SAN FRANCISCO OTHER THAN HAVING
OCCASIONALLY A DECENT FOOTBALL
TEAM. AND A FORMERLY GREAT
BASKETBALL TEAM BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER CONVERSATION SAN
FRANCISCO HAS HOSTED AN IRISH
CONSULATE GENERAL SINCE
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE. AND LAST
SEPTEMBER CALIFORNIA BECAME THE
FIRST STATE TO WELCOME A SECOND
IRISH CONSULATE. ITS LOCATION
IN LOS ANGELES IS FITTING AS
IRELAND IS THE SEVENTH LARGEST
FOREIGN INVESTOR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE CONSULATE
WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT FOCUS
ON THE CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
LOCATED THERE. PRIOR TO HER
APPOINTMENT AS THE FIRST
COUNCIL GENERAL IN LA MS KEANE
WORK IN IRELAND'S UNITED
NATIONS OFFICE IN GENEVA AND AS
PART OF THEIR PERMANENT
REPRESENTATION. TO THE EUROPEAN
UNION IN BRUSSELS. HER
EXTENSIVE RESUME INCLUDES WORK
ON A NUMBER OF KEY ISSUES AMONG
THEM HUMAN RIGHTS IN SOUTH
AFRICA THE PEACE PROCESS IN
NORTHERN IRELAND AND BREXIT.
IRELAND'S DIPLOMATS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO PARAMOUNT
TO THE ORGANIZATION OF A VERY
SUCCESSFUL SENATE DELEGATION TO
OUR ISLAND THAT I WAS HONORED
TO LEAD THIS PAST NOVEMBER.
THEIR EFFORTS HELPED ENSURE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT
IRELAND'S DATA PROTECTION
EFFORTS WORK ON BREXIT. THEIR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT POLICIES
AND THE CONSULTATION OF
GOVERNMENT MODEL WHICH THEY USE
I WAS PARTICULARLY INSPIRED.
NOT JUST BY THE GREAT IRISH
WHISKEY THAT'S PARENTHETICAL
IT'S NOT IN MY NOTES AND THE
BEST BEER AND GUINNESS STOUT
STUFF IS QUITE EXTRAORDINARY-
WHICH THE IRISH APPRECIATE TIED
WOULD SAY IN GREAT MEASURE BUT
I WAS PARTICULARLY INSPIRED BY
THE THEIR IMPLEMENTATION OF KEY
SOCIAL CHANGES. THAT PROMOTED
INCLUSIVITY REFERENDUM. WITH
REMARKABLE MARGINS THEY
LEGALIZE SAME SEX MARRIAGE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND LIBERALIZED
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TRULY THE TIES WE HAVE
WITH OUR IRISH FRIENDS ARE TOO
NUMEROUS TO MENTION- FROM THE
FOUNDATION F THE IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIP OR FORM THE
FOUNDATION OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIP. NOT THE LEAST OF
WHICH IS THE FACT THE TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS CLAIM
IRISH DESCENT AND I MIGHT ADD
ON SAINT PATRICK'S DAY IT'S
PROBABLY ABOUT TEN TIMES THAT
AMOUNT. BUT IT IS A ROBUST A
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP AND FRIENDSHIP
THAT INCLUDES 15% OF U. S.
IMPORTS TO IRELAND COME FROM
CALIFORNIA. SO THE VALUE OF OUR
PARTNERSHIP IN RELATIONSHIP
HERE. IS SIGNIFICANT AND THE
FACT THAT THERE IS NOW A NEW
CONSULAR OFFICE IN LOS ANGELES
I THINK WE'LL CERTAINLY AT
LEAST DOUBLE THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO CONTINUE THAT WARM AND
WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP. AND
NOTICE WE HAVE A WOMAN IN THAT
POSITION AND OF COURSE SO IT'S
DOUBLY. OF MY HONOR PRIVILEGES
DOUBLED BY THAT FACT THE GREAT
THE PEOPLE OF IRELAND AND THE
GREAT CONSULAR A GENERAL- FROM
IRELAND- PLEASE GIVE A WARM
WELCOME TO ORALLY KEEN WHO IS
WITH US TODAY.
A HEARTY SENATE
WELCOME TO THE NEW COUNCIL
GENERAL. WELCOME. MOVING ON
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE AN INTRODUCTION FROM
THE GALLERY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
MATTER PRESENT WE HAVE SOME
SPECIAL FOLKS WHO ARE WITH US
AT THE SENATE TODAY HARD WORK
AND SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS SCHOOL
BOARD PRESIDENT SUPERINTENDENTS
IN STUDENT TRUSTEES ARE IN THE
GALLERY WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO OFFER THEM A HEARTY HAPPY
NEW YEAR AS WELL AS A WELCOME
TO THE CALIFORNIA. STATE SENATE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
AND WELCOME TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FOR. OUR
CENTER MORE LIKE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. WITH THE
PRIVILEGE OF HAVING THREE GRAND
CHILDREN THAT RESIDE CURRENTLY
IN WISCONSIN. I WOULD LIKE TO
AT LEAST MAKE THE POINT. THAT
THE GREEN BAY PACKERS. HAD A
QUARTERBACK THAT WAS BORN IN
CHICO CALIFORNIA AND- HAD AN
EXCELLENT CAREER CAL BERKELEY
AND- WE SHOULD TO BE PROUD THAT
CALIFORNIA HAD A- ON OF ITS OWN
IN THE GAME ON SUNDAY- SO WE
SHOULD. BE VERY PROUD OF AARON
RODGERS IN. CONGRATULATE THE
FORTY NINERS AND WISH THEM ALL
THE BEST IN TWO WEEKS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT SENATOR MORE LIKE
YOU OPEN THE DOOR AGAIN SENATOR
PORTANTINO YES UNDER PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR NOW I'M NOT
PICKING AS TEAM IN THE
SUPERBOWL BUT I DO HAVE TO-
EXERT A LITTLE PRIDE OF THE
COACH OF THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS
SANDY REID- IS A LA NATIVE WHO
GREW UP IN. A SENATOR DURAZO'S
DISTRICT THAT JOHN MARSHALL
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEN STARTED
HIS COLLEGE CAREER AT GLENDALE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE TWENTY
FIFTH SENATE DISTRICT SO OF
COURSE WE'RE PROUD OF ANDY REID
AND THE CHIEFS THIS YEAR AS
WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT. ANY OTHER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. THING THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ BUDGET MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR JANUARY
TWENTY FIRST THROUGH THE TWENTY
THIRD TO TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU PASS WILL
BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND READING
UPON BEING REPORTED AND ORDERED
TO THIRD READING. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURE MEASURES
REPORTED TODAY AND TOMORROW
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION DO PASS
AS AMENDED WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURNED TO SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED.
I'M WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES
REPORTED ON FRIDAY WITH AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED AND
PUBLISHED. INTRODUCTION AND
READ AND FIRST READING OF BILLS.
BILLS ARE DEEMED READ.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
WE'LL TAKE UP SENATE THIRD
READING. ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY A SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR RUBIO AN
ACT RELATING TO RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY INSURANCE. THANK YOU
PRESIDENTE MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB SEVEN FIFTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TO HOMEOWNERS WHO
PURCHASE THEIR POLICY OVER THE
PHONE OR ONLINE WHEN THEY ARE
NON RENEWED BY THEIR INSURERS
WHEN MOST INSURERS FILTERING
YOUR POLICY THEY MUST NOTIFY
THE CONSUMER OF THE AVAILABLE
ALTERNATIVE SOURCES OF
COVERAGES. FOR INSURANCE
INCLUDING THROUGH THE FAIR PLAN
AND SURPLUS LINE BROKERS SB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE EXPANDS THE
APPLICABILITY OF THE NOTICE SO
INSURERS DO NOT SELL POLICY
THREE AGENTS OR BROKERS BUT
MUST ALSO PROVIDE THIS NOTICE
WHEN IT IS NON RENEWED.
CONNECTING CONSUMERS WITH THE
COVERAGE THEY NEED IS CRITICAL
TO STABILIZING BE INSURANCE
MARKET THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
SENATOR JACKSON'S YES I WANT TO
THANK THE GOOD SENATOR FOR THIS
MEASURE BUT ALSO ADDED CAVEA
OUT THAT. WE'RE GOING TO AN
EPIDEMIC NOW OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT ARE REFUSING TO
RENEW THEY ARE NON RENEWING
PEOPLE I KNOW IN MY DISTRICT
AND- MANY OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE SO WHILE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THEY PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION. OUT TO OTHERS AND
I WANT TO THANK THE GOOD
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK DEEPER AT
THE BECAUSE OF THESE NON
RENEWALS AND DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERS HAVE
ACCESS TO GOOD INSURANCE GOING
FORWARD SO. I WILL LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT DISCUSSION THIS YEAR
AND- WANT- CAN I VOTE ON THIS.
VERY BASIC BUT IMPORTANT
MEASURE WHILE WE HAVE A BIGGER
DISCUSSION FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE RIGHT NOW
SUFFERING THROUGH THE- AGONY
AND UNCERTAINTY OF THE NEXT
STAGE IN THEIR INSURANCE WORLD.
AND OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING THEN SENATOR RUBIO YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. NOT JUST THANK
YOU FOR THEN IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE TO
FIND OUT REAL PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS AND TO HELP OUR FOLKS
CELL SO YEAH THIS IS A SMALL
STAFF JUST IN HELPING RELIEF
RIGHT NOW BUT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK AS COLLEAGUES
AND GROUPS TEND TO FIGURE OUT A
MORE PERMANENT SOLUTION WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
OF MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A MEMBER
OFF THE FLOOR SO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THE GOAL TO THE ROLL CALL
ONCE AND THEN WILL- MOVE THE
CALL. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES I FELL.
I FOR JUST I BRADFORD I CUT BY
ADAM I CHIANG. DOLLY I DODD. I
THEY'RE AWESOME. GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH I
HERTZBERG I HILL. I HUESO AYE
TADO HI JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. I MORE LOCK I MORRELL
FIVE NIELSEN I PAN I PORTANTINO
HI ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I UMBERG I WHITE HOUSE
SKI. I WIENER I WILK HI.
MEMBERS IT APPEARS AS IF WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE SO WE'LL GO
THROUGH THE ROLL CALL AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. ATKINS CHIANG. THE RAZA
BY. OKAY. OKAY. I THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX.
SENATOR HALEY PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
HELL AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. SENATOR
HILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES ALL VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENTS ARE CRITICAL IN
MANY COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE A PAID FIRE
DEPARTMENT MAY NOT BE FISCALLY
POSSIBLE. INTO TWENTY FIFTEEN I
AUTHORED SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
WHICH EXEMPTED ALL VOLUNTEER
FIRE DEPARTMENTS FROM HAVING TO
PAY SALES TAX ON THEIR FUND
RAISING EFFORTS. THE EXEMPTION
WILL SUNSET ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SB THIRTY
EIGHT WILL REMOVE THE SUNSET
ALLOWING THESE EXTRAORDINARY
VOLUNTEERS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITH
ALL OF THE RESOURCES OF THEIR
FUNDRAISING. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE COLLEAGUES. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS CENTER DOLLY THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY OF SUPPORT
THE BILL. I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY CRAPPIE DOUBLY GOING TO
OVER THE NEXT MONTH- TO SUPPORT
THESE LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS
BUT YES THEY DO NEED TO KEEP
THOSE RESOURCES. THERE TO DO
THE SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU
FOR THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THE COURAGE AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR HELL YOU MAY
CONCLUDE FOR FREE AS RIVAL
COLLEGE THANK YOU. MEMBERS IF
THERE IS ACTUALLY ROLL CALL ON
THIS ONE- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES I FELL
I GORGEOUS. I BRADFORD HI COME
BY ADAM I CHIANG. DOLLY AYE
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW FIVE
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO TADO
I JACKSON AYE JONES. FIVE LEYVA
I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK AYE MORRELL. I
NIELSEN I PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
I NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
CHIANG. GALGIANI AYE HUESO.
FIVE I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SENATOR
BRADFORD ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
SENATE BILL TWO OH THREE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATING TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
CENTER BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SB TO ALL THREE SIMPLY UPDATES
THE LIFELINE PROGRAM A PROGRAM
THAT WAS. INSTITUTED ABOUT FOUR
YEARS AGO BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WHEN MORE WHICH AFFORDS MILLION
TO CALIFORNIA'S DISCOUNT ON
THEIR PHONE SERVICES AND A
BRINGS STATE LAW INTO
CONFORMITY WITH THE US FEDERAL
FCC. TO ALLOW OVER TWO MILLION
PEOPLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS PROGRAMMERS BUT CLASS
PRIVATE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE SENATOR BRADFORD YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THE THING MORE. SIX
THING NO CONCLUSION HELP SORRY
I THE IDEA OF HUESO WAS BOTHER.
I WAS OFFERING YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONCLUDE IF NOT
RESPECTFULLY AS RIVAL THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL- EXCUSE ME THIS TEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IF THERE IS NO OBJECTION.
SAYING NO OBJECTION THIRTY
SEVEN I KNOW ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. ARE YOU
PREPARED ON ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
PLEASE PLEASE READ THE PLEASE
READ MADAM SECRETARY. SENATE
BILL FIVE TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS ENTITIES. SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT A
PRESIDENT AS BRILLIANT AS WE
ARE AS LAWMAKERS SOMETIMES
THERE ARE MISTAKES OR
INCONSISTENCIES THAT NEED
CORRECTION AS WE A MODERNIZE
THE LAW. FOR THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN FORMING
CORPORATIONS AND NOW WE HAVE
THESE NEW ENTITIES RELATIVE TO
AN OLD LAWYER LIKE ME OF ELLO
PEAS AND LLC'S AS WE CREATED
THESE NEW ENTITIES WILL CREATED
DIFFERENT STANDARDS BY WHICH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE UTILIZES
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY CAN
APPROVE A NAME. SECRETARY
PADILLA HOURS GREAT SECRETARY
OF STATE HAS COME UP WITH AN
APPROACH TO DO ONE STANDARD
APPROACH SAY THE OFFICE A BUNCH
OF TIME MODERNIZE THE PROCESS
AND ENHANCE THE PROTECTION OF
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BEHALF OF US
SECRETARY PADILLA SPONSOR THIS
MEASURE. I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
SENATOR HERTZBERG ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. NOTHING THANK YOU I
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY THE ROPE
BOX USE ME THIS ITEM AGAIN IS-
WITHOUT OBJECTION IT- THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SENATOR
HILL. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN OH TWO
BY SENATOR HELL AND ACTUALLY
DID TO ENERGY THE FLOORS ARE
SENATOR HANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR KALI JUST BE SEVEN
OH TWO MAKES A MINOR CHANGE TO
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD STATUTES LONG TERM
CONTRACTING PROVISION THE GOES
INTO AFFECT IS COMING NEXT
JANUARY UNDER EXISTING LAW
CUSTOMERS THAT CHOOSE TO
DIRECTLY PROCURE RENEWABLE
RESOURCES SUCH AS STANFORD
UNIVERSITY MAY DO SO AND HAVE
THEIR OUR PS CREDITS COUNT FOR
THE RETAIL SELLER. HOWEVER
BEGINNING JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THAT ELIGIBILITY IS REVOKED
MERELY BECAUSE STANFORD NOT
THEIR RETAIL SELLER IS HOLDING
ON TO THE LONG TERM CONTRACTS
THIS WAS NOT THE INTENT OF THE-OUR PS THE LONG TERM
CONTRACTING PROVISIONS IN THE
OUR PS WERE INTENDED TO ENSURE
MARKET CERTAINTY AND RENEWABLE
DEVELOPMENT STANFORD HAS TAKEN
AN AGGRESSIVE APPROACH TO
REDUCING THEIR GHG. EMISSIONS
SB SEVERAL TO INSURE STANFORD
LONG TERM RENEWABLE CONTRACTS
CONTINUE TO BE COUNTED
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS VOTE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. SEEING AS HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS OR IS
YOUR SENATOR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT THE SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY THIS BILL ESTABLISHES AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO EVALUATE
THE STEPS CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE
TO HELP IMPROVE THE LICENSURE
OF ADVANCED PRACTICE
RADIOLOGICAL TECHNICIANS. THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ESTABLISHES
ESTABLISHED BY THIS BILLWILL
EVALUATE WHAT IS CURRENTLY
BEING DONE IN CALIFORNIA IN
REGARDS TO THE LICENSE YOUR AND
CAN BE DONE TO HELP MEET THE
EVER INCREASING DEMAND FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BY
IMPLEMENTING FURTHER STUDY INTO
HOW CALIFORNIA CAN BEST
RECOGNIZES PRACTICE NOT ONLY DO
WE CREATE FURTHER OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO RECEIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. BUT WE
CAN ALSO CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT IS WELCOMING TO OUR
VETERANS WHO ARE RETURNING HOME
AND SEEKING POSITIONS. MANY OF
WHOM HAVE ADVANCED RADIOLOGICAL
TRADING. I HOPE THIS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FIND ACTIONABLE DATA
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN USE TO HELP
VETERANS AND SEVEN RETRAIN
CIVILIANS TO OBTAIN LICENSURE
IN THEIR EXPANDING MEDICAL
PRACTICE THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE THIS
ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IF THERE
ARE NO OBJECTIONS. SEEING NONE
I IS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.MOVING ON
MEMBERS TO ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
SENATOR MINING HE IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR MINING AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
CENTER MINOR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
RENAMES THE CALIFORNIA SEA
OTTER FUND THE SEA OTTER
VOLUNTARY TAX CONTRIBUTION FUND
AND EXTENDS THE FUN TO TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
HAVE GENEROUSLY CONTRIBUTED TO
THE SEA OTTER FUND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
USES THE FUNDS IT RECEIVES
PERCY HONOR CONSERVATION
INCLUDING INCREASED
INVESTIGATION PREVENTION AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS RELATED TO
SEA OTTER MORTALITY. THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY USES THE
FUNDS IT RECEIVES TO HELP
SCIENTISTS BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE CAUSES OF SEA OTTER
MORTALITY AND DEVELOP GUIDANCE
TO AID IN HONOR RECOVERY. I
WOULD ALSO ADD THE RESEARCH
TIES INTO INVESTIGATION OF
CLIMATE IMPACTS BOTH OCEAN
IMPACTS IN COASTAL IMPACTS IN
THE SEA OTTER PROVIDES AN
ATTRACTION TO OUR TOURISM
INDUSTRY AND JOBS AS WELL HIRED
HERE I'VE VOTE. IS THERE A
DISCUSSION OR TO ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR WESSEL. I JUST WANT TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW- SEA OTTERS
ARE VERY THREATENED SPECIES AND
JUST SOMETHING A LITTLE OF
ASTERISK IN HISTORY. BACK IN
THE SEVENTEEN HUNDREDS- ONE OF
THE LEADING IN- INDUSTRIES IN
BAKA CALIFORNIA. AND CLOSE TO
COUPLE SAN LUCAS DOWN THERE BY
MAGDALENA BAY ONE OF THE
LEADING INDUSTRIES AT THAT TIME
WAS SEA OTTER SKINS. IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE THERE WERE SEE OTTERS
AS FAR SOUTH IN OUR STATE SAN
DIEGO. ALL THE WAY DOWN TO A
COUPLE SAN LUCAS AND NOW- THERE
ONLY A MAINLY FOUND IN THE
MONTEREY BAY AREA AND IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S- JUST A VERY SAD STATE
OF AFFAIRS THAT WE FIND ON OUR
EARTH THAT THE SPECIES ARE
BEING PUSHED FURTHER- FURTHER
INTO SMALLER LOCATIONS. AND SO
FOR THIS POPULATION IN
PARTICULAR TO VERY NON.
IMPORTANT SPECIES IN OUR STATE
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
OF THE FOR HIS WORK ON
CONSERVANCY IN WORKING TO
PRESERVE THE SPECIES THANK YOU
MADAM. PRESIDENT CENTER
MOORLACH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- THIS FUND HAS BEEN
RECEIVING IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
MINIMUM SO IT'S ACTUALLY A
SUCCESSFUL- VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION ON THE FORM FIVE
FORTY SO THAT'S- I THINK IT
SPEAKS REALLY WELL- FOR THIS
PARTICULAR. BECAUSE THE. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WE'VE GOT JUST
SOME SELECTED. CATEGORIES AND
IT'S FILLING UP ALMOST A PAGE
AND A HALF NOW. AND WE HAVE SO
MANY GOOD NON PROFITS IN THE
STATE SO I THINK WE STOOD STILL
LOOK AT REVAMPING THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION. COMPONENT OF THE
FORM FIVE FORTY- BECAUSE LESS
THAN 2% OF TAXPAYERS ARE EVEN
USING- THAT OPPORTUNITY BUT I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR.
TAKING SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
HAD A LEGISLATIVE DEADLINE IT'S
NOT BEING EXTENDED BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT PERFORMING AND
MEETING THE STANDARDS IT'S JUST
SOMETHING THAT HAD TO BE DONE.
WITHIN THE CURRENT CODE SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN CENTER MONNING YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR COMMENTS.
IT'S A PART OF THIS BILL DOES
CONFORM TO RECENT LEGISLATION
THAT DOES INCLUDE IN THE NAME
VOLUNTARY TAX CONTRIBUTION FUND
THAT'S BEEN DONE FOR ALL OF
THOSE. VOLUNTARY SELECTIONS ON
THE STATE TAX RETURN MEMBER.
RICHER AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IF SAYING NO OBJECTION. I
IS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZEROS
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SENATOR PAN
HE IS READY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE
TO KOREAN AMERICAN DAY. CENTER
PAN THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS- AYE THIS VICE CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AT RICE
PRESENT STR SEVENTY EIGHT
COMMEMORATING THE ARRIVAL OF
THE FIRST THREE AND IMMIGRANTS
TO THE UNITED STATES IN
NINETEEN OH THREE. WITH
DILIGENCE FORTITUDE AND A
DURING BELIEF IN AMERICAN DREAM
KOREAN IMMIGRANTS HAVE HELPED
TURN EMERGING AREAS WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INTO
THRIVING RESPECTABLE
COMMUNITIES WELL THE FIRST CAME
FROM HAWAII OVER TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND THEN MOVED TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY
ESTABLISHED A STRONG.
THROUGHOUT CITY CALIFORNIA WE
CONTINUE TO APPRECIATE THE
NUMEROUS VALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
KOREAN AMERICANS HAE MADE TO
THE UNITED STATES A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS MEMBERS OF OUR
MILITARY FAITH LEADERS AND MANY
OTHER ROLES. WITH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK I.
COMMEMORATING THIS IMPORTANT-
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
THANK YOU. SENATOR RUBIO. YEAH
PRESIDENT OF MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
RESOLUTION SIXTY EIGHT
PRESENTED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M A PROUD. HOLLY
REPRESENT A VERY LARGE
COMMUNITY OF ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AND THE SINGLE VALLEY
AND ALSO PROBABLY SERVE ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ASIAN
POSITION PACIFIC ISLANDER
AFFAIRS I RECENTLY HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF ATTENDING CHINESE
LUNAR NEW YEARS AND- I THINK
LAST YEAR I DID SIXTEEN I'M
TRYING TO OUTDO MYSELF THIS
TIME IS JUST EXTREMELY AN-
INCREDIBLY FUN TO PARTICIPATE
AND JUST SEE THE CULTURE
DIVERSE CITY AND- AND SO I
REALLY ENCOURAGE EVERYONE HERE
AND- ANYONE. WATCHING TWO THREE
GO OUT AND TRY AND BE PART OF
THAT IN A FINE AND IN THEIR
COMMUNITY I CALIFORNIA'S HOME
OVER FIVE MILLION ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN CONTRIBUTE TO
THE STATE'S COLD PRO. AND
ECONOMIC SUCCESS I. DO. TO THAT
THEIR EXPERIENCE BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS AS
LEADERS WERE ALWAYS VERY
MINDFUL DATA THERE'S A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY THAT WE REPRESENT AND
I JUST SO ENJOYED SO I
RESPECTFULLY ALSO ASKED THAT WE
SUPPORTED THANK YOU. SENATOR
AWESOME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT- IN MY
DISTRICT IS THE LARGEST-
COMMUNITY OF KOREAN AMERICANS-
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS ARE NOT
ONLY- TO RAISE THE- ISSUES OF
KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY THE
HISTORY THE CULTURE. ALL ALL OF
THE WAYS IN WHICH THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COMMUNITY OUR
SOCIETY BUT THEY ARE IN FACT
COMPLETELY INTEGRATED INTO THE
REST OF THE COMMUNITY. THEY
REPRESENT THE NEEDS THE
ASPIRATIONS OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY WHICH IS ALSO VERY
LARGE AND LIVE WITHIN- THE
CORRECT KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SO I WANT TO THANK
THEM ON BEHALF OF EVERYONE. FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP WHAT A FIVE
FOUR HOW THEY'VE STRUGGLED IN
THE COUNTRY AS IMMIGRANTS AND
THE WAYS THAT THEY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR NATION THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SING NINE
CENTER PAN YOU MAY CONCLUDE I
JUST WANT THANK- MIGHT GOOD
COLLEAGUES FOR SPEAKING OUT
ALSO. STORES RESOLUTION- I KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CELEBRATE A
LUNAR NEW YEAR ON SATURDAY WILL
HAVE A RESOLUTION COMMEMORATE
DOWN MONDAY BUDGETS ARE. ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IF THERE'S
NO OBJECTION. SAYING NINE FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION PASSES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE FOR TODAY SO
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YOU YOU HAVE
BEEN ADJOURNED IN MEMORY AND SO
IF EVERYONE COULD PLEASE GIVE
ME SENATOR ARCHULETA YOUR
ATTENTION THAT. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. MY FELLOW SENATORS
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US HAS
GREAT STAFF MEMBERS AND EVERY
ONCE IN AWHILE STAFF MEMBER OF
THE FAMILY SOMETHING WILL
HAPPEN SOME SIGNS IT'S JOYFUL
BECAUSE IT'S A WEDDING OTHER
TIMES THE BIRTH OF A CHILD AND
OTHER TIMES IT'S A DEATH IN THE
FAMILY. AND I SADLY IT TO SHARE
WITH YOU A DEATH- OF ONE OF OUR-
THE MEMBERS THAT THAT HANDLES
OUR MILITARY VETERANS
COMMITTEE. SHE LOST HER MOTHER.
AND SHE LOST HER BROTHER. SO A
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM.
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY IN
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF. AUTUMN
HELLO AND WILLIAM HELLO. THE
MOTHER AND BROTHER. OF MY
SENATE VETERANS- AFFAIRS
ASSISTANT CINDY BALDWIN CITY
OBVIOUSLY BEEN WORKING HARD TO
REPRESENT OUR VETERANS EVERY
SINGLE DAY SO I'M SO SAD FOR
HER AND HER FAMILY. WILLIAM
HELLO THE WAY ON SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN.
WILLIAM WAS BORN IN APRIL
TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY
NINE IN ERIE PENNSYLVANIA AND
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILLIAM
WAS KNOWN WHOSE BY FRIENDS AND
FAMILY IS BILL MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA WITH HIS FAMILY AND
STARTED HIS PROFESSIONAL CAREER
IN HIS DAD FURNITURE SHOP
DURING HIS HIGH SCHOOL YEARS
SELLING FURNITURE. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT BILL STARTED
WORKING FOR GOOD YOUR TIRES AND
QUICKLY CLIMBED THE CORPORATE
LADDER BECOMING A REGIONAL
SALES MANAGER. YEARS LATER
THERE WAS FORCED INTO EARLY
RETIREMENT WHEN HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THE BILL WOULDN'T
GIVE UP. NEVER THE LAST HE KEPT
GOING ON EVEN THOUGH THE
DIAGNOSES FOUND HIM. WITH SUCH
CRIPPLING. RESULTS HE KEPT
PUSHING ON AND- A STUDENT THAT
T. JUST LOVE BEING WAY BACK
FROM HIGH SCHOOL HE WENT ON TO
CONTINUE HIS PASSION FOR
LEARNING BUT WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL OF GRADUATE FROM SHARE
COLLEGE WITH HIS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS DEGREE.
BILL STARTED HIS MS SOCIETIES
SUPPORT GROUP. AND NOW AUBURN
AREA AND VOLUNTEERED WITH THE
AREA WESTERN PLACE YOUR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT HELP SET THE
SET UP THE COMPUTER SYSTEM TO
HELP THE STUDENTS BILL WAS AN
INSPIRATION TO HIS FRIENDS AND
FAMILY AND FREQUENTLY EXPRESSED
THAT HE HAD A WONDERFUL LIFE IT
WAS A VERY VERY LUCKY. BILL IN
SYDNEY'S MOTHER AUTUMN HELLO
PASSED AWAY JUST A MONTH AGO
AFTER HIS SON. IN OCTOBER.
OCTOBER THE EIGHTH TO BE EXACT
OVER THE EIGHTH AT THE AGE OF
NINETY TWO. AUTUMN GRADUATED
FROM RICE SEVEN YOU UNION HIGH
SCHOOL IN GERARD PENNSYLVANIA
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. IN HIGH
SCHOOL SHE WAS A LIBRARY CLUB
MEMBER. A SCIENCE CLUB
VOLLEYBALL CLUB. AND TO LEADERS
SENIOR CLASS IN- SO MANY PLAYS
THERE AT SCHOOL IT IS SUPPORTED
IN HER YEARBOOK. ALTHOUGH SHE'S
A TINY LASS SHE'S THE BELL OF
THE CLASS AND- SHE WAS A SOCIAL
BUTTERFLY IN OUR COMMUNITY SHE
WAS- VERY MUCH INVOLVED HER
BRIDGE CLUB THE PURPLE HATS
CLUB. IN MANY OTHERS EVEN IN
HER LATER YEARS IN HER EIGHTIES
HE WAS BUSIER THAN EVER. AND
SHE ALWAYS WAS INVOLVED IN THE
COMMUNITY HE WAS A LIGHTNESS
SPARKLE OF EVERYONE THAT SHE
MET. AND IT WAS A HEAVY HEART.
THAT I ASKED THE SENATE TODAY
TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF WILLIAM
HELLO. AND HIS MOTHER AUTUMN
HELLO. AND IT REMEMBER IN OUR
STAFF MEMBERS- SO IF WE CAN
JUST PAUSE FOR A SECOND. TO
REMEMBER ANYONE IN OUR FAMILIES
PASSED AWAY LAST YEAR AND MAYBE
ILL TODAY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. PLEASE EXTEND OUR
SENATE CONDOLENCES AND A ROOM
BRING THEIR NAMES TO THEIR
DESKS SO THAT THEY CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED
THANK YOU FOR THAT. SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IN MEMORY MEMBERS I-
RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HONOR OF NANCY SMITH
A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS WOMAN THE
CITY OF WESTMINSTER WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY SECOND OF THIS
YEAR AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY SIX
BUT NANCY SMITH WAS BORN IN
BATH MAINE IN NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE AND MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
AS A YOUNG ADULT WHERE SHE MET
AND MARRIED- CHUCK SMITH CHUCK
SMITH WAS- CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
MAYOR AND SUPERVISOR IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND FRIEND OF SENATOR
JOHN MORLOCK. SHE WAS A DEVOUT
MEMBER OF OUR CHURCH IN VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND CHARITIES
WHERE SHE WAS ALSO LEADER THE
WESTMINSTER COMMUNITY THEATER
LATER GIRL SCOUTS SO OPTIMISTIC
AND SHELTER FOR THE HOMELESS-
SHE'LL BE REMEMBERED DEARLY
BUYER CHILDREN ROBIN JEFF STACY
SCOTT HER NINE GRANDCHILDREN
AND SEVEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN I
US THAT WE ADJOURN IN NANCY
SMITH'S MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG PLEASE BRING HER
NAME TO THE DESK SO THAT SHE
CAN BE APART APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED YOU HAVE ANOTHER
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY AS I
UNDERSTAND. I DO OF THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMORY MEMBERS-
I RISE. THIS MORNING TO ASK
THAT WE JOURNAL MEMBER MEMORY
OF A MEMBER OF. THE GREATEST
GENERATION FACT AN EXAMPLE FOR
ALL OF US- MARSHALL SMALL WAS A
TRAILBLAZING ATTORNEY VETERAN
AND FRIEND. HE WAS BORN IN
KANSAS CITY MISSOURI IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN THE FIRST
CAME TO THE BAY AREA IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR TO ATTEND
STANFORD UNIVERSITY BUT DROPPED
OUT HE DROPPED OUT OF STANFORD.
NOR TO ENLIST IN THE MERCHANT
MARINE WHERE HE SERVED- DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. AFTER RETURNING
FROM SERVICE HE WENT BACK TO
STANFORD EARNED HIS
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE AND HIS
LAW DEGREE. AFTER EARNING HIS
LAW DEGREE HE CLERK FOR SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE WILLIAM O.
DOUGLAS- DURING THE NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE FIFTY TWO TERM AND
THEN AFTER THAT DURING THE
KOREAN WAR HE WENT INTO THE
ARMY ANY SERVER THE GENERAL
COUNSEL'S. OFFICE OF THE ARMY
AND WAS THERE IN PARTICIPATED
IN THE VERY FAMOUS ARMY
MCCARTHY HEARINGS THAT MANY OF
US MAY NOT RECALL BUT I'VE READ
ABOUT IN TERMS OF. SENATOR JOE
MCCARTHY- BEING A DEMAGOGUE AND
ACCUSING A NUMBER OF PATRIOTIC
AMERICANS OF BEING COMMUNISTS-
BOB AFTER THE KOREAN WAR- IT.
HE RETURNED TO THE BAY AREA ANY
FORMS TO LIFELONG ASSOCIATIONS
FIRST BY MARRYING HIS WIFE WHO
SADLY RECENTLY DIED AS WELL-
THEY WERE MARRIED. HE AND MARY
WERE MARRIED OVER SIXTY THREE
YEARS IN BY JOINING- MORRISON
AND FOERSTER LAW FIRM. IT WAS
AT MORRISON FOERSTER THAT HE
AND I WERE COLLEAGUES FOR OVER
A DECADE- MARSHALL WAS A
PARTNER AT MORRISON FOERSTER E
WAS THE MANAGING PARTNER ANY IS
THE CHAIRMAN. BUT I KNEW HIM AS
GENERAL COUNSEL AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT A GENERAL CAN SO DOES
IN A LAW FIRM. THAT THE PERSON
IS STILL WITH GREATEST
ADJOURNMENT NOT JUST THE-
SMARTEST LAWYER BUT ALSO THE
PERSON WHO'S WILLING TO MAKE
VERY HARD DECISIONS IN A PERSON
WHO SERVES AS AN EXAMPLE FOR
ALL THE OTHER LAWYERS IN THE
OFFICE TO LOOK UP TO- HE ALSO.
WAS VERY ACTIVE BESIDES
REPRESENTING. A LARGE LARGE
CLIENTS ACTIVE IN PRO BONO
PRACTICE IN FACT HE
REPRESENTED- THERE WAS A POINT
TO REPRESENT. BEFORE THE US
SUPREME COURT OF A IN IN MADE
IN SAN QUENTIN WHO WAS
CONVICTED OF MURDER. AND HE
ALSO WAS ACTIVE IN HIS
COMMUNITY HE WILL HAS A
TEACHER'S ASSISTANT. IN A
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO. HE LEFT AN IMPACT ON
EVERYONE INCLUDING ME. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER LIZ
HER HUSBAND DANIEL HIS SON DAN
AND HIS WIFE JUST DEAN AND HIS
GRANDSON ALEXANDER- MEMBERS I
ASKED TODAY THAT WE ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING HIS NAME
FORWARD AS- GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON HIS
LIFE OF COMMITMENT TO. TO OUR
COUNTRY AND OUR STATE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING HIM HIS FORWARD IT
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A GREAT
CALIFORNIA A GREAT AMERICAN
FORMER SOME WOMEN PAUL TO CAR.
BUT NOW I. MR BUT NOW I WAS THE
FIRST JAPANESE AMERICAN ELECTED
TO THIS BODY AND SERVE FOR
EIGHT YEARS HE DIED ON
SEPTEMBER FOURTEENTH. AT THE
RIVER NICE AGE OF NINETY NINE
HE WAS BORN IN DELTA COLORADO
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO JAPANESE
IMMIGRANTS MISTER BERNARD SPENT
MUCH OF HIS CHILDHOOD IN SMALL
MINING AND FARMING TOWN THE
COLORADO UTAH AND ARIZONA UNTIL
HIS FAMILY RELOCATED TO BOYLE
HEIGHTS WERE YOU GRADUATED FROM
HIGH SCHOOL. DURING WORLD WAR
TWO HE WAS FORCED. INTO
INTERMENT CAMPS IMAGINAR DUE TO
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINETY SIXTY
SIX BUT DESPITE THAT MISTER BUT
NOT CHOSE TO SERVE HIS COUNTRY
AND JOINED THE MIGHTY FOR TO GO
FOR BROKE. REGIMENT IN COMBAT
IN TRAIN WITH THE FIVE TWENTY
TWO FIELD ARTILLERY BATTALION
BEFORE BEING ASSIGNED TO
MILITARY INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
HE SERVED IN NEW GUINEA AND
ELSEWHERE IN THE SOUTH PACIFIC
INCLUDING YOU A COMBINED US AND
AUSTRALIAN FORCES AND WAS AN
INTERPRETER. FOR THE FORMER'S
FORMAL SURRENDER OF THE
JAPANESE FORCES IN INDONESIA
UPON RETURNING LOS ANGELES
AFTER THE WAR MR BUT NOW I WAS
MARRIED AND HE MOVED TO THE
CITY OF GARDENA. IF OF THE
MANAGER DOWNTOWN FLOWERS
MARKETING ALSO BECAME HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN LOCAL JAPANESE
COMMUNITIES AND WORK WITH- WITH
A BANK IN LITTLE TOKYO- PRIOR
TO THE WAR. HE WANTED TO CAREER
REALLY STATE INSURANCE AND
BANKING WAS ELECTED TO GUARDINO
CITY COUNCIL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR FOUR HE WAS
ELECTED. AS THE STATE TO FOUR
TERMS TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY MAKING HIM THE FIRST
JAPANESE AMERICAN TO SERVE IN
THE LEGISLATURE DURING HIS
TENURE HE REPRESENTED THE FIFTY
SECOND AND SIXTY SEVEN. OUR
DISTRICT AND WHILE SERVING ON
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE FINANCE
INSURANCE VETERANS AFFAIRS WAYS
AND MEANS AND RULES COMMITTEE.
POLLAN'S CAREER IN ASSEMBLY HE
BECAME THE FIRST DIRECTOR. OF
THE COMMISSION ON WARTIME.
RELOCATION AND INTERMENTS A
CIVILIANS. WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
AND HELP PUBLIC HEARINGS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. ITS
FINDINGS WERE KEY TO AWARDING
RESTITUTION AND APOLOGIES TO
JAPANESE AMERICANS INCARCERATED
DORM MORE WORK TO IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE HE WAS APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN TO
SERVE AS CHIEF MORRELL FAIRS
DIRECTOR. AT THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION EARNING THE VA
ADMINISTRATORS EXCEPTIONAL
SERVICE AWARD UPON HIS
RETIREMENT. MR BUT NOW I SPENT
BY THE LAST TWENTY YEARS OF HIS
LIFE ATTENDING EVENTS
THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF GARDENA
AND DESPITE THE NEW FANGLED.
CAMERAS AND DIGITAL CAMERAS MR
BUT NOT NOT I WOULD ALWAYS BE
SEEN AROUND CITY OF GUARDINO
WITH HIS BELOVED. FUJI CAMERA
WORRY STILL USE FAIL ANY TOOK
PICTURES OF ALL THE EVENTS AND
I TOOK GREAT DELIGHT AND
RECEIVING. A ENVELOPE FOR
MISTER MARTIN I WISH SCRIBBLING
HAND RIDING WITH A PICTURE IN
THERE UP SOME OF THAT THAT HE
YEAH I WAS OUT THAT HE HAD
TAKEN A PICTURE OF ME WILL
ALWAYS WITH A NICE NOTE
ATTACHED. AND AS YOU GOT OLDER
THE PITCHERS GOT A LITTLE MORE
BLURRY A LITTLE OUT OF FOCUS
BUT HE WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT IT
AND HE WAS LOVED AND HE WILL BE
MISSED IN THE CITY OF GUARDINO
BE MISSING THIS INSTITUTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING HIS NAME
FORWARD AND MAKE SURE YOU BRING
IT TO THE DESK SO THAT HE CAN
BE. APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZING
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY.
CENTER BRADFORD YOU HAVE
ANOTHER ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
THAT I DO MEMBERS I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY
OF ELTON DO HAN. IF YOU'RE A
GOLFER IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY WHO WAS A FAMILIAR
NAME MR DO HARM WAS BORN IN
LAFAYETTE LOUISIANA NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE. AND BECAME A
UNIQUE PIONEER FOR AFTER
AMERICAN GOLF. AFTER
DISCOVERING HIS LOVE AND
PASSION FOR THE SPORT IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE. MR DO
OUGHT TO GO BACK OFF AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE HE WAS
FEARFUL HE WAS BECOMING
ALCOHOLIC. ANY NEEDED SOMETHING
TO GET HIM AWAY FROM DRINKING
AND HE FELL IN LOVE WOULD GO
OFF AND WITHIN THE YEAR. IT WAS
PLAIN IN CHAMPIONSHIP
TOURNAMENTS THAT'S HOW MUCH HE
COMMITTED HIMSELF TO THE GAME.
A LONG TIME MEMBER THE
COSMETOLOGY GOLF CLUB. P.
EARNED AN AMAZING RECORDS
WINNING CLUB ANNUAL TOURNAMENT
SEVEN CONSECUTIVE YEARS IN A
ROW. HE WAS THE FIRST MAN LOS
SANDERS TO WIN THREE MAJOR
TITLES WITHIN ONLY ONE YEAR THE
FIRST AND ONLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN- TO WIN THE UNITED
STATES MEN'S. AMATEUR GOLF
CHAMPIONSHIP IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO. HE WAS ACCOMPLISHED HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WERE DEEM SO
IMPRESSIVE BY. THE MAYOR TOM
BRADLEY DECLARED NOVEMBER
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
IS OUT TO HONG DAY IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. HE CONTINUED TO
BE RECOGNIZED BY BOTH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. SUPERVISORS AND
THE BOARD OF PARKS AND
RECREATION'S FOR. HIS COUGHING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS- BEGINNING HIS
PROFESSIONAL CAREER AT THE
YOUNG AND CAPABLE AGE OF
SEVENTY SEVEN ME SIXTY SEVEN HE
JOINED. WHAT WAS THEN THE
SENIOR TOUR WHICH IS NOW KNOWN
AS THE CHAMPIONS TOUR. ALL OVER
THE YEARS MISTER DO HAN
DEDICATED HIS TIME TO ENTER TO
SING THOUSANDS OF YOUNG FOLKS.
AT FOLKS TO THE GAME OF GOLF AT
JUST WATCHING THE GOLF COURSE
THAT I GREW UP AND I LEARNED A
GAME OF OFF THEIR- HE WAS A
MENTOR AND FRIEND TO MANY- HE'S
IN THE HALL OF FAME- AFTER
AMERICANS GOLFERS HALL OF FAME
IN ARIZONA. INTERNATIONAL BLOCK
OFFERS HALL OF FAME IN AUBURN
ALABAMA HE TRAVELED AROUND THIS
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD
TAKING YOUNG FOLKS TO ST
ANDREWS. TO JAPAN TO CHINA TO
PLAY GOLF- HE IMPACTED MANY OF
THAT OUR PROFESSION FROM TIGER
WOODS- WAS ONE OF HIS. MANY
MENTORS. AND HE WAS A FRIEND TO
ME AT Mà I'M- TO ME. I ALWAYS
CALL HIM. MR DO ON MANY FOLKS
WAS CAUGHT ON DUTY BUT LIKE HE
WAS ALWAYS MISTER DO HANA MAE.
AND HE WOULD THIS SIZE YOUR
GAME UP BY A HANDSHAKE IN NEW
SO AS HE SHOOK YOUR HAND IF YOU
HAD CALLUSES AND NOT GIVE YOU A
CALIFORNIA AND HE KNEW YOU
COULDN'T PLAY GOLF YOU KNEW.
YOU WEREN'T A GOOD GOLFER AT I.
SO WHERE THOSE OF YOU WHO
CALLUSES BY I. EACH IS PASSION
THE GAME AND HIM. MY LIFE AND I
LOW THE GAME OF GOLF BECAUSE OF
PEOPLE LIKE MR DO HAN HE'LL BE
SORELY MISS AND I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS OF. MR DO HAN AND
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO WE CAN APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZE HIM. MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES OUR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR WILK
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM TODAY WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE WE WILL RECONVENE
BACK HERE ON MONDAY AT TWO PM
MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
YES SENATOR PORTANTINO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT YES
MADAM PRESIDENT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT TEN FIFTEEN IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM.